[Music]
the u.s
has surpassed another terrible
coronavirus milestone
with more than 10 million reported cases
and of course it's only expected to get
worse
so far the pandemic has claimed nearly
240
000 lives in the u.s including parents
siblings friends artists and essential
workers
we are continuing to share the stories
of the remarkable people that we've lost
here are just some of the many lives to
remember
[Music]
helen jones woods was a founding member
of the international sweethearts of
rhythm
a racially integrated all-female band
that toured the world in the 1930s and
40s
woods picked up the trombone at 13 as
she told a smithsonian panel
in 2011. i like watching the slide go up
and down you know
could i could go up and down too so why
the hell do i
why don't i take that play that
instrument you know
in 1944 downbeat magazine rated the
sweethearts america's
number one female band but as woods
recalled they weren't always welcome
in the jim crow south the sweethearts
broke up in 1949
and woods joined the omaha symphony but
she was fired when the orchestra
discovered
she was black so she worked for 30 years
as a nurse and raised four children
helen jones woods was 96.
dr john d marshall ran a family practice
in south georgia for more than three
decades
my uncle was a rock star in america's
georgia
said rasheed marshall he had his hand in
every little thing
in that city dr marshall jd to his
friends
headed the naacp chapter for 14 years
and started the local newspaper the
america
sumpter observer serving as
editor-in-chief
dr marshall was still running the paper
and caring for his patients
when he caught the coronavirus he would
spend 111 days
on a ventilator he worked until he could
not work
anymore said his niece leslie marshall
we truly lost an angel dr john d
marshall was 74.
[Music]
brian fonseca was a dramatic force in
indianapolis
theater a producer and director who
championed voices
whose stories hadn't been told good
theater has always been
commentary on the political and social
aspects of every community
in which it serves fonseca first started
a storefront theater in his hometown of
gary indiana
in 1983 in indianapolis he co-founded
the phoenix theater
which he led for 35 years
two years ago he put his name on a new
company
the fonseca theater made up of 80
percent
people of color he gave me a shot
he's done that for countless artists
said jordan flores schwartz
now the theater's interim director when
fonseca got coveted
he held staff meetings from the hospital
till just days before he died
he had a laugh that could fill a room
said schwartz
it's weird to think i'll never hear that
voice again
brian fonseca was 65.
andrea mahmann was a clinical
psychologist and mother
in illinois she was hands down the most
beautiful soul i have ever met
said her husband matt they met in
kindergarten
became close friends in high school and
married in 2013.
andrea worked for nine years to get her
psychology degree
and was devoted to her patients andy was
a very accepting person said her mom
kathy smith she just wanted people to
feel good about themselves
and their differences in may
matt and andy bought their dream home so
their son russ
now three had a big backyard to play in
then in august they all caught the
coronavirus
matt and russ fought it off but andes
lingered
just days after his mother died russ
called out one night to his father
dada he said it's just going to be you
and me now
right yup matt answered just you and me
andrea maman was 37.
gosh that chokes me up every time you
know it's like this is what you
this is what we're dealing with here and
what's left behind the people
you know people having to pick up after
all of this i mean
brian fonseca usually did the christmas
production every year and he's not going
to be doing it this year
behind it's just another reminder i'm so
glad you do these as hard as they are
that these are people behind all these
numbers and cases they are
all right you know you hear people say
oh it affects virtually nobody is that
nobody
i mean there's a lot of somebody we'll
be right back you're watching cbs this
morning